gibt rahmen geben muss in denen dann
wettbewerb und innovationen laufen
können und vonstatten gehen können und
das werden dann an anderen punkten
ebenso das thema mindestlohn hat jan
breiten raum eingenommen armin laschet
macht es den eindruck als vertrete hier
die interessen von arbeitgebern und
arbeitnehmern der tarifparteien das ist
mitnichten der fall die gewerkschaften
stehen ganz allen deutlich dazu dass wir
die mindestlöhne erhöhen müssen dass wir
sichern müssen dass jede und jeder ein
auskommen mit seinem lohn hat zwölf euro
mindestlohn ist nicht viel aber es ist
zumindest eine grundlage und sich
dagegen zu stellen heisst gegen zehn
millionen menschen die profitieren
würden wenn es diesen mindestlohn gäbe
wir haben auf der anderen seite auch
wieder erlebt die alte leier davon dass
wenn man steuern pauschal senkt dann und
vor allen dingen für die großen für die
oberen einkommen und vermögen dass das
am ende zu mehr einnahmen für den staat
führt ich glaube das hat es mal gegeben
in brasilien als die steuern dort über
60 prozent waren es gibt es sicher nicht
in mitteleuropa
wir haben selbst die erfahrung gemacht
dass die steuerreform anfang des
jahrtausends ein großes loch in den
haushalt gerissen hat es ist
anschließend ein stück geschlossen
wurden mit einer mehrwertsteuererhöhung
wir haben unsere erfahrungen damals
gemacht und wir wissen dass so eine
solide staatsfinanzierung nicht
funktioniert dass wir eben setzen müssen
auf investitionen auf öffentliche
investitionen dazu gibt es eine reihe
von aussagen eben auch von arbeitgeber
wirtschaftsinstituten und dass wir auf
private investitionen setzen müssen und
die punktuell auch unterstützen anreize
da wo innovation wo transformationen wo
klimaschutz zu erwarten ist ist richtig
aber nicht zu glauben dass einfach eine
pauschale abschaffung von steuern oder
senkung von steuern für die obersten
einkommen und vermögen automatisch zu
einer besseren politik und zu einer
nachhaltigen politik und einer politik
für das gemeinwohl sorgen wir glauben
nicht an das laufen lassen wir glauben
daran dass wir gemeinsam mit allen
gruppen in der gesellschaft auch der
wirtschaft auch der umwelt vertretungen
auch der sozial vertretungen eine gute
politik aufsetzen können olaf scholz ist
dafür diejenigen auch gestern noch
einmal bewiesen hat dass er diese 1
enden zusammen bringt ganz anders als
die politische konkurrenz von der
konservativen seite
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
auch von meiner seite herzlich
willkommen wir haben tatsächlich heute
morgen im präsidium den gestrigen abend
aber auch den vorgestrigen tag in
münchen noch mal revue passieren lassen
analysiert und deutlich auch die
auffassung geteilt die ja auch die
mehrheit der zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer von gestern abend geteilt
haben wir haben den souveränen wir haben
einen kompetenten und wir haben den
sympathischen kanzlerkandidaten erlebt
mit olaf schulz
industriellen haben wir immer wieder
zeigen können dass wir mit unserem
zukunftsprogramm auf die richtigen
themen setzen im gegensatz zum
kandidaten der union auch inhaltlich
überzeugen können wir haben gestern
abend tatsächlich gehört norbert walter
borjans hat es angesprochen dass
ganz offensichtlich das konzept des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns insgesamt
ablehnt denn er hat nicht nur von der
höhe gesprochen die ablehnen so dann
insgesamt gesagt er finde die löhne
seien in den händen der tarif partner
wir haben den gesetzlichen mindestlohn
mit cdu und csu in der vergangenen
legislatur gemeinsam eingeführt er ist
ein erfolgskonzept der hat die kaufkraft
der der niedrigen einkommen erhöht und
das muss auch weiter geschehen es ist
schon ziemlich erstaunlich dass der
kanzlerkandidat der cdu csu dieses
konzept inhaltlich nicht verstanden hat
die menschen in diesem land wollen
lösungen die wollen ideen und konzepte
wie wir vorankommen wie wir leben
verbessern und diese konzepte haben olaf
schulz und hat die spd und das konnten
wir gestern abend auch noch mal konnte
olaf scholz gestern abend auch einmal
sehr deutlich zeigen wir können uns ein
weiter so nicht leisten nicht in umwelt-
und klimafragen nicht in den sozialen
fragen
gerechtigkeitsfragen dieses landes bei
der bildung bei der pflege bei der
gesundheit und auch nicht im
wirtschaftlichen bereich und bin ich
gern ralph brinkhaus höhere die
ankündigung von ralph brinkhaus an die
cdu wolle die menschen ein jahr lang in
lang in ruhe lassen dann kann ich das
nur als kapitulationserklärung werden
ich kann
gerne mir auch vorstellen dass die cdu
die menschen vier jahre lang in ruhe
lässt und ob er auf der oppositionsbank
platz nehmen am samstag hat oder schulz
in münchen eine große schar von
zuschauern und zuschauern zu hören und
zu hören begeistert das war wirklich
eine veranstaltung mit einer sehr sehr
guten stimmung auch nicht nur unsere
leute sondern auch interessiertes
publikum die eben von den themen die wir
transportieren auch beeindruckt sind so
erleben wir jetzt also auch an jedem
infostand und an jeder haustür in der
wir klingeln dann dass die menschen mit
den mit den themen die wir setzen den
mindestlohn dem bezahlbaren wohnen der
stabilen rennteam und natürlich den
klimaschutz ja auch ganz klar konform
gehen und sagen das sind die themen die
uns wirklich auch unter den nägeln
brennen am samstag hat olaf scholz in
münchen ein papier zum wohnen
vorgestellt wie soll bezahlbares wohnen
möglich gemacht werden es hier soll ein
bündnis für bezahlbaren wo bezahlbare
wohnungen geben öffentliche hand und
privatwirtschaft müssen da nämlich an
den handarbeiten damit wohnungen in
sozialbindung entstehen können jedes
jahr 100.000 zumindest und insgesamt
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr das ist
eine erhöhung des wohnungsbaus neben den
wir dringend brauchen ich denke wir
können auch darüber hinaus gehen die
derzeit sind die handwerker und
bauunternehmen sehr stark unter last es
wird viel gebaut in deutschland aber wir
müssen da wirklich noch eine schippe
drauflegen wir werden aber nicht so
schnell den
wohnungsmangel beseitigen können vor
allem in den in den städten natürlich
angespannt die wohnungsmärkte müssen
deswegen beschützt werden mieterinnen
und mieter müssen geschützt werden vor
explodierenden mieten mit einem mieten
moratorium wir werden natürlich heilen
was wir jetzt in der großen koalition in
der ausgehenden legislatur ertragen
mussten nämlich dass der co2 preis
alleine durch die mieter getragen wird
im gegenteil sind wir der auffassung
dieser co2 preis im gebäudesektor muss
von den vermietern getragen werden denn
die haben ihr einfluss darauf indem sie
die häuser besser dämmen bessere fenster
einbauen eine klimafreundliche wohnung
heizung einbauen dadurch ist eben der
co2 ausstoß verringert und damit auch
der co2 preis die mieter können wird die
heizung runterdrehen und haben es kalt
diese soziale kälte ist für uns nicht
akzeptabel wir haben weiter auf den
diesen papier vorgelegt eine idee für
gemeinwohl orientiertes bauen und wohnen
gemeinnützigkeit und wir haben natürlich
auch die bodenpolitik und der
baulandpolitik dort noch einmal deutlich
gemacht die das wohnen voranbringen
insgesamt ein programm das sich sehen
lassen kann das dazu führen wird dass
menschen nicht weiterhin mehr als 50
prozent im niedriglohnsektor oder
mindestens mal mehr als ein drittel
ihres einkommens fürs wohnen aufbringen
müssen das können so nicht weitergehen
vielen dank die erste frage kommt von
basil wegener dpa
nun ist die union in einigen umfragen
wenn es schon kein auf eine aufholjagd
war so doch rechts nach wieder an die
spd heran gerückt
heute muss sich der
kandidat im ausschuss fragen stellen wie
stark belastet
die debatte jetzt um geldwäsche und die
finanzkennzahlen
die letzten tage noch und
hätten sie eigentlich vor ich sage mal
zehn tagen oder so gedacht dass es noch
so knapp werden würde auf den letzten
metern überhaupt
also warum erstens immer gesagt es ist
kein selbstläufer wir müssen jeden tag
überzeugungsarbeit leisten das habe ich
gerade auch nochmal für die letzte woche
an alle auch in der spd adressiert die
vor ort wahlkampf machen der zweite
punkt ist was sich im augenblick
verändert hat ist nicht die
größenordnung für die spd sondern wir
wissen dass es eine gewisse verschiebung
offenbar zwischen cdu und fdp geben kann
aber am ende doch sehr stark davon
geprägt ist dass auf der konservativen
und auf der liberalen seite das zutrauen
in die person von armin laschet sehr
gering ist
und verlässlichkeit und stabilität
anders daherkommt als mit dem verhalten
von armin laschet in den letzten tagen
was den jetzt gegenwärtigen punkt der
financial intelligence unit angeht da
bin ich einfach mal ganz kurz noch etwas
sagen aus meiner eigenen zeit als
finanzminister damals ist nämlich
finanzminister von nordrhein westfalen
damals hat wolfgang schäuble etwas
verändert was wir alle nicht so gut
gehalten haben es war nämlich so dass
die geldwäsche von der wir wissen dass
die runde 100 milliarden im jahr
ausmacht und in deutschland viel zu
wenig bekämpft worden ist in der
vergangenheit die wurde bekämpft von
275 bzw 300 personen davon waren 25 beim
bundeskriminalamt und 275 bei den
landeskriminalämtern
wolfgang schäuble hat sich damals dafür
loben lassen dass er die 25 aus dem
bundeskriminalamt in den zoll übertragen
hat und gesagt hat sich verdoppelt die
also 50 das heißt man hatte am ende
statt der 300 weil nämlich die
landeskriminalämter plötzlich mit ihrer
gesamten kompetenz draußen waren hatte
man 50 statt 300 und das hat olaf scholz
übernommen und olaf scholz hat aus den
50 mittlerweile über 400 450 gemacht und
in den haushalten ist schon geplant eine
aufstockung die über 700 geht das heißt
also er hat konsequenzen gezogen er hat
die zentralisierung gelassen hat aber
ganz klar gesagt wir müssen dann aber
über das damalige maß hinausgehen das
ist alles in die wege geleitet worden
und wenn sich heute ein kanzlerkandidat
von cdu/csu hinstellt und so tut als
wenn in dieser zeit der geldwäsche der
geldwäschebekämpfung nicht mehr das
interesse gewidmet worden wäre dass es
in der vergangenheit hatte dann ist das
absolut eine unverschämtheit und wenn
jetzt nachgeforscht was bei dieser
einzelnen einheit zu ändern ist und
dafür nach adressen gesucht wird im
bundesfinanzministerium
man weiß das glaube ich jeder
einzuschätzen was es bedeutet werden ein
kanzlerkandidat daraus einen skandal
machen will ich halt was für ein skandal
mit diesem thema so umzugehen die
geldwäschebekämpfung wie viele andere
bereiche der steuerhinterziehungs
bekämpfung sind unter olaf scholz extrem
verstärkt ausgebaut worden und sie
gehören auch noch weiter ausgeweitet
nächste frage kommt von clement von der
ard
ja auch eine nachfrage zum selben thema
herr walter borjans aus ihrer
perspektive damals wie sinnvoll ist es
an dieser zentralisierung festzuhalten
das fällt ja dann schon in die
zuständigkeit auch von herrn scholz und
in seiner amtszeit und die zweite frage
wie groß war denn der druck dass er
heute jetzt doch im ausschuss erschienen
ist was so habe ich das jedenfalls
interpretiert ja selbst der spd
vertreter im ausschuss kurz vorher nicht
wirklich wusste
also erstmal ist glaube ich in diesem
wirklich sehr zentralen bereich schwerer
kriminalität auch eine zentralisierte
bekämpfung gut wünschenswert der fehler
der damals passiert ist ist das eben auf
eine hohe kompetenz der
landeskriminalämter von einem auf den
anderen tag verzichtet worden ist und
man praktisch neu aufbauen musste also
es ist nicht die zentralisierung an sich
sondern es ist einfach das ja das
verzichten auf hohe kompetenz und das
muss sehr schnell nachgeholt werden und
das ist ja in den vergangenen jahren
auch eingeleitet worden das macht man
aber nicht von heute auf morgen der
andere punkt ist der ich kann jetzt die
beweggründe im einzelnen nicht
nachvollziehen aber ich kann nur sagen
aus einer eigenen einschätzung heraus
wenn man sieht was für eine
skandalisierung aus einer geschichte
gemacht werden soll die offenbar nur
noch der letzte strohhalm für ein
laschet ist dann würde ich an dieser
stelle auch sagen dann werde ich mich in
diesen ausschuss setzen es ist immer
kann sich das vorstellen in diesen tagen
ein enormes problem termine zu finden
nun termine zu verlegen aber dann halte
ich eine solche geste auch an den
ausschuss für absolut honorable und das
ist das was offenbar jetzt auch passiert
ist aber das eigentlich was dahinter
liegt ist er versucht daraus etwas zu
machen weil die cdu offenbar keinen
inhalt hat sucht sie danach wie
skandalisieren ich die anderen
die nächste frage kommt von nicole
kunath auch ard die nachbarin
die eine frage haben sie mit dem
kollegen schon beantwortet zu der
plötzlichen sinneswandel von herrn
choice heute aufzutauchen die andere
frage gestern premiere gab es ja schon
erste liebesbekundungen was die eine
zusammenarbeit mit den grünen angeht
aber das wird nicht reichen was ist für
sie beide jetzt quasi die rote linie
richtung linkspartei aber auch richtung
liberale die nicht überschritten werden
kann nach für weitere
koalitionsverhandlungen nach der wahl
also wir haben jetzt ist wenn ich das
immer wenn sie nicht gut ist wenn wir
sagen würden hier jetzt vorgegeben
sondern ich glaube das ist eine eine
geschichte gibt wir wollen cdu und csu
nach allem was ich eben auch gesagt hat
auf die oppositionsbank bringen glaubt
dass wollen auch sehr viele menschen in
deutschland und das bedeutet dass man
dann natürlich die übereinstimmung mit
den grünen die vorhanden ist auch noch
einmal deutlich heraus kehrt und
aber auch dabei dass diskussionen geben
und auf dieser grundlage werden wir dann
weiter reden
alles gesagt
wir haben jetzt in den nächsten sechs
tagen nochmal die wichtige aufgabe auf
die haben wir uns auch die morgen
verständigt um alle möglichen stimmen
für die spd zu bewerben weil wir diese
stimmen brauchen damit olaf schulz
kanzler werden kann das ist jetzt unsere
aufgabe das ist auch der unser einziger
focus und deswegen werden wir alle diese
fragen wie sie haben nach der wahl im
angesicht des ergebnisses der wirklichen
auch abgegebenen stimmen und nicht von
prognosen und meinungsumfragen
besprechen erst mal unter uns und dann
sicher gerne auch mit ihnen
die nächste frage kommt von
feinschmecker von rtl
frage an sie beide vsg gestern abend
haben sie sich stark gemacht für
investitionen es ist ja nun bekannt dass
olaf scholz
er investitionen moderat entgegensieht
und
da wäre meine frage jetzt nach der wahl
wenn wir auf die zeit nach der wahl
blicken wie groß ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es da dann zu
inhaltlichen differenzen zwischen ihrem
kanzlerkandidaten und der partei kommt
weil vor dem hinblick kevin kühnert zum
beispiel auch angekündigt kommt es zu
einer neuen kroko legte alle parteiämter
nieder also wie groß ist die gefahr dass
es da noch mal tracht in ihrer partei
wir haben unser zukunftsprogramm und wir
haben die arbeit in der aktuellen
regierung über all die monate jetzt
monate gemeinsam gestaltet die arbeiten
in der aktuellen regierung hat ein
massives investitionsprogramm mit sich
gebracht zwar nicht nur ein
konjunkturprogramm sondern auch eines
das viele investition in investitionen
in die zukunft enthalten hat und genau
so ist es auch mit dem zukunftsprogramm
dass viele investitionen enthält der
öffentlichen hand die dringend notwendig
sind für bildung für digitalisierung
fürs wohnen und die werden sich nicht
ohne mittel der öffentlichen hand
umsetzen lassen da gibt es gar keine
unterschiedlichen meinungen zwischen
olaf schulz und uns beiden oder anderen
teilen der partei wir haben dieses
zukunftsprogramm ihr gemeinsam
geschrieben und gemeinsam beschlossen
ein bundesparteitag steht dahinter
unsere 400.000 mitglieder stehen
dahinter sie dürfen darauf vertrauen
dass wir das nach der wahl auch umsetzen
ich will vielleicht noch dazu sagen dass
olaf scholz investitionen zurückhalten
zieht ist definitiv nicht richtig wir
haben nachdem wir bei dem parteitag auf
dem wir gewählt worden sind ja auch
einen beschluss gefasst haben dazu ein
leitantrag verabschiedet haben der
gerade dieses investitions thema in den
mittelpunkt gerückt hat der noch einmal
unterstrichen hat was sowohl
arbeitgeberseite als auch
arbeitnehmerseite aus wirtschaft aus
ihrer wirtschaftsinstituten
herausfordern dass wir das da
unterstrichen haben wir haben dann in
einem koalitionsausschuss vor corona
gemeinsam diese position gegenüber dem
koalitionspartner auch noch mal deutlich
waren und beschlossen das ganze wie
gesagt ist durch brunner noch einmal
deutlich verstärkt worden die frage ist
doch jetzt wirklich nur
was bedeutet das für die finanzierung
und was bedeutet es für die umsetzung
und es gibt einen punkt da sind in dem
sind wir schon sowieso absolut einer
meinung nämlich dass wir dafür sorgen
dass gelder die zur verfügung stellen
auch abfließen können da gibt es noch
eine menge klemmen das sehen wir dass
viele bereitstehenden mittel am ende so
nicht abgeflossen sind da muss was
passieren
und der zweite punkt ist dass wenn sie
abfließen wir natürlich auch
finanzquellen brauchen deswegen sagen
wir übereinstimmend gemeinsam jetzt ist
keine zeit für steuersenkungen für hoch
verdienende und hoch vermögende für
pauschale steuersenkungen sondern für 95
prozent der einkommensbezieher und der
zweite punkt ist dass wir in unserem
programm stehen haben das über die kfw
als investitions und innovationsagentur
eben auch mittel generiert werden also
insofern ist das alles passt miteinander
zusammen sagt aber auch deutlich ja
natürlich wird es auch mittel geben die
am ende
vernünftig als anteil dessen was zukunft
schafft auch mit krediten finanziert
werden können aber eben im rahmen der
geltenden gesetzlichen bestimmungen
vielleicht noch anfügen auch
konservative und liberale sprechen von
einem massiven investitionsbedarf ist
bleibt nur geheimnis wie sie es bei
steuersenkungen im volumen von zwischen
30 und 90 milliarden je nachdem welche
partei man nimmt finanzieren wollen das
ist tatsächlich wo du was sie da
betreiben
die nächste wortmeldung kam von den
kollegen 23 mitte ja fabian busch von
web.de und gmx sie haben eben gesagt sie
wollen die übereinstimmung mit den
grünen noch deutlicher herauskehren was
kann man sich darunter vorstellen also
kann es auch noch so einen kleinen
lagerwahlkampf geben wie 2002 da ist ja
letztendlich auch erfolgreich für rot
grün
ich fand die aussage von annalena
baerbock schon ich sage jetzt mal
bemerkenswert dass sie ja auch deutlich
gemacht hat dass die grünen einen
partner für die regierungsbildung in der
spd sehen und wenn man sich die
programme einmal übereinander legt dann
ist das ja auch nicht verwunderlich wir
sagen wir sind trotzdem wettbewerber
jeder will für sich zur möglichst großer
stärke kommen weil wir eben auch noch
mal
diese verbindung nicht eingangs gesagt
habe und für die urlaubs scholz auch
steht nämlich die sorgen der gegenwart
mit dem was für die zukunft zu tun ist
zusammenzubringen das heißt mit anderen
worten transformationen
sozialverträglich zu gestalten
meinen wir die richtige kraft zu sein
aber das ist ja viele über ein
überschneidende punkt und gibt ist kein
geheimnis und aber das wird dann auch
gesprächen vorbehalten sein wie weit man
da kommt
noch eine frage von kai clement von der
1 ich würde gern noch mal die these von
herrn dobrindt ansprechen wonach nur die
stärkste fraktion so zu sagen vielleicht
das moralische wenn auch nicht dass
legale recht hat in eine
regierungsbildung zu starten wie
bewerten sie diese these so eng wie das
rennen jetzt werden könnte könnte das ja
sowohl ihre als auch die fraktion der
union betreffen und die geschichte zeigt
ja auch dass es gegenbeispiele gibt also
wie bewerten sie diese idee von herrn
dobrindt also ich finde grundsätzlich
spannend dass herr dobrindt und ja auch
andere dann jetzt zu wenige tage vor der
wahl beginnen darüber zu spekulieren und
auch schon offenbar abschließend darüber
zu spekulieren wie die wahl ausgeht wir
mal haben sind getragen von demut
gegenüber dem votum der wählerinnen und
wähler und sprechen über diese dinge am
wahlabend beziehungsweise am tag danach
ich glaube dass die dass das eine sehr
vergifteter hinweis ist und zwar nicht
in unsere richtung sondern an die
adresse des kanzlerkandidaten weil
daraus schon wieder spricht dass der
zwist der in der cdu/csu tief sitzt
fortgeführt wird und das muss man sich
eben anschließend angucken bei uns gilt
alle können mit allen reden wir haben
oft mehrheiten gehabt in der
vergangenheit bei der die spd nicht die
stärkste fraktion war und wenn ich
darauf vor wochen bestanden habe und
diese position vertreten habe dann gibt
es auch keinen grund das zu ändern wenn
wir vorne liegen und andere nicht also
wer miteinander spricht das entscheiden
die partner selbst dass man sich
angucken muss wenn es zu einem
deutlichen minus bei der cdu käme dass
darin eher eine frage liegt wie man
daraus den anspruch auf eine regierung
ableitet dass eine andere frage aber die
haben wir nicht zu beantworten die
nächste frage hatte der kollege herab
der linken seite
ja stefan bei der kraft von halo
vielleicht können sie mir helfen bei der
ausbeutung von äußerungen von olaf
scholz wenn ich das richtig sehe hat er
gesagt es wird keine spd geführte
regierung geben ohne mindestlohn 12 euro
das sagt ja schon seit längerem und ohne
rentengarantie
das ist doch wenn ich das richtig
verstehe rote linie für eine
spd-geführte regierung das ist ein
versprechen das wird kommen erste frage
sehen sie das auch so und die zweite
gehört zu dieser roten linie erweiterbar
sie haben es gerade angedeutet die spd
will keine steuersenkungen ist das auch
eine harte forderung der rote linie für
eine mögliche nächste regierung
also ich finde
ich bleibe dabei dass man in
pressekonferenzen
nicht
ausschlusskriterien
setzt und diskutiert die hinterher wenn
man zu einem ergebnis kommen müssen
besprochen werden müssen aber in
gesprächen punkte an die für uns
essentiell sind der mindestlohn ist ein
zentrales thema unserer wahlkampagne so
wie es eben auch faire löhne sind und
mieten renten das haben sie gerade
angesprochen
das sind punkte an denen werden wir auch
nach einer erfolgreichen wahl
gemessen und der zweite punkt ist jeder
der mich kennt weiß dass ich diese frage
einer gerechten besteuerung für eine
sehr wichtige halte und daraus kann man
schon ableiten dass es zu jedem weiteren
möglichen partnern in reihe von
richtigen knackpunkten gibt die zu lösen
wären aber das ist dann wirklich etwas
was man nicht im vorfeld den anderen
über die medien signalisiert sondern man
sich an einen tisch setzen und sagt gibt
es eine schnittmenge die ausreicht oder
gibt es sie nicht
da sind ja im vorfeld jetzt der wahl
auch schon andere themen klar gesetzt
worden sie haben jetzt am samstag dieses
wohnungspolitische konzept gesehen ein
nur ein aspekt davon nämlich das bauen
von 400.000 wohnungen steht auf den
plakaten
dahinter steht ein konzept so ist es mit
dem mindestlohn der begleitet ist von
der von dem in der klaren überzeugung
wir wollen wieder mehr tarifbindung wir
wollen die tarifbindung wieder zum
normalfall machen wir wollen
unbefristete beschäftigung wieder zum
normalfall machen da steckt sozusagen
auch hinter diesem kurz begriff der eben
auf den auf den plakaten steht und so
ist es auch mit der mit der ehrlichen
bilanz dessen wie viel strom wir
brauchen um dieses land klimaneutral zu
machen uns vor allem die wirtschaft wie
man neutral die industrie klimaneutral
zu machen da müsste tatsächlich auch in
den ersten in den ersten wochen der plan
auf den tisch wie bauen wir die
erneuerbaren energien und die stromnetze
so aus dass uns der wert dieser wandel
auch gelingt
tobias peter von
frau s herr walter borjans für wie
verlässlich belastbar halten sie die
aussage der grünen dass man wirklich
lieber mit ihnen regieren möchte oder
anders gefragt wie groß schätzen sie die
gefahr ein falls die fdp sich bei der
ampel ziert sperrt wie auch immer das
die grünen doch relativ bereitwillig
sagen natürlich können wir uns auch
schon mal vorstellen
lieber ist ja keine ausschuss prinzip
also insofern nämlich das so zur
kenntnis wie es gesagt worden ist im
respekt davor dass eine konkurrierende
partei sich ihre gedanken machen wird
und das dann aber ihren wählerinnen und
wählern ihren mitgliedern auch erklären
muss aber ich nehme erst einmal zur
kenntnis dass diese übereinstimmung in
vielen wichtigen punkten gerade des
klimaschutzes und
der der investition der digitalisierung
dass das wichtige punkte sind und alles
andere wie gesagt wird sich zeigen wenn
miteinander gesprochen wird und wenn die
knackpunkte mit anderen oder auch
untereinander deutlich heraus kommen
also es ist nicht so dass wir jetzt hier
alle da stehen und wissen schon wie die
harmonische lösungen für die tage nach
der wahl aussehen wird auch olaf scholz
hat ja schon sehr deutlich gesagt dass
er sich eine regierung mit den grünen
gut vorstellen kann und wünscht andere
sprechen davon dass ihnen die fantasie
für eine zusammenarbeit fehlt ich hoffe
dass die dennoch wächst vor allem dass
wir gespräche führen können das ist
jetzt ganz klar unser plan ein gutes
ergebnis erstmal zu erzählen und dann
auch gespräche dabei zu führen nicht mit
den rechtsradikalen von afd das ist ganz
klar und was wir über die
regierungsfähigkeit der cdu csu gesagt
haben das haben sie ja auch schon auf
dem zettel
nochmal von rtl
heute nachmittag stellt die union ihr
zukunftspapier neustadt für die
kreativwirtschaft vor wie sind denn ihre
ideen für den neustart einer
kreativwirtschaft und welche hoffnungen
und perspektiven können sie den künstler
in den konzertveranstalter innen denn
bieten
da ist ja in den vergangenen monaten
schon schon viel gemeinsam entwickelt
worden wir haben sehr sehr viele
schalten webex konferenzen oder zoom
konferenzen mit kreativen und und
veranstaltungen gehabt weil die
natürlich die die eine eine von mehreren
sehr gebeutelten branchen durch die
korona pandemie sind aber natürlich hat
die korona pandemie wie bei allen
anderen
fällen auch deutlich gemacht was vorher
eben schon schief lag dass kultur nicht
sehr häufig bei den bei den kommunen als
als freiwilligkeit aufgabe gesehen wird
wies der definition nach auch deswegen
wollen wir kultur als staatsziel im
grundgesetz verankern dafür brauchen wir
starke mehrheiten aber das ist ein
wichtiges ziel damit wir eben auch dafür
sorgen können mit entsprechender
bundesunterstützung dass die kultur
genauso wie die gastronomie und genauso
wie der einzelhandel auch teil des
lebens in unseren innenstädten ist und
bleibt und und auch in ihrer vielfalt
erhalten bleibt
gibt es weitere fragen herr wegner
bitteschön
frau wissler und herbert haben vorhin
noch mal betont es gebe gute grundlagen
für gespräche mit spd und grünen
überhaupt hat er ja schon die tage
eingriffe so versichert dass der nato
ein nato austritt jetzt irgendwie keine
bedingung für die linken sei oder sowas
deswegen die frage dieser schmusekurs
dieser absolute bereitschaft auf der
regierungs wille der linken ist dass er
weiß was sie unterstützt weil diese
option dann auch nach einem
möglicherweise schwierigen wahlergebnis
auf dem bahndamm auf dem tisch bleibt
oder müssen sie das erste befürchten
weil es doch diese rot-rot-grün ängste
die es vielleicht in der bevölkerung
gibt merkt also ich habe immer gesagt
was die linke in ihrem programm an
guten themen hat das haben wir in
machbar und realistisch und was sie an
tim hat die glaube ich auf eine große
ablehnung in der mehrheit der
bevölkerung stoßen würden die gehen eben
mich wenn sie auf dem tisch blieben auf
der anderen seite habe ich genau so
gesagt das gibt es eben auch mit den
anderen und ich bleibe dabei dass wir
alle miteinander gesprächsfähig sein
müssen das heißt also wir sollten nicht
jetzt das fell des bären verteilen wir
haben in den nächsten wochen war die der
souverän sind die wählerinnen und wähler
und auf dieser grundlage müssten die
parteien miteinander sprechen können die
knackpunkte in die eine wie in die
andere richtung sind benannt aber
nochmal es sind eben auch jenseits von
nato eine reihe von themen die an sich
von der themenstellung gut sind aber die
in der sag mal in der dosierung etwas
sind fast sicher zu einem großen problem
führen wird aber das kann man auch nicht
vorher lösen
wir arbeiten in den nächsten tagen jetzt
erst mal daran dass wir nicht ein
schwieriges sondern ein gutes ergebnis
bekommen da gibt es noch eine menge
unentschlossener unentschieden
wählerinnen und wähler zu überzeugen das
ist jetzt erstmal unser fokus und dann
werden wir nach der wahl gespräche
führen
dann sehe ich jetzt keine weiteren
fragen mehr dann wünschen wir ihnen noch
einen guten tag vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und die kommen
ja das war die pressekonferenz von
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
den vorsitzenden der sozialdemokraten
wir warten jetzt und wollen ihnen gleich
zeigen eine pressekonferenz der cdu
heute vormittag kam das cdu präsidium zu
kommen und auch der zusammen und der
bundesvorstand und wir erwarten jetzt
eine pressekonferenz des cdu
vorsitzenden und kanzlerkandidaten armin
laschet thema